so what about like you interviewing me
what would you ask me if you were gonna
interview me well first I saw your
audition for American Idol yeah so I
would one love to know why you decided
to sing outlast I would also love to
know because I know that you made your
own clothing for it
right yes so I would love to know if you
would ever consider becoming a fashion
designer and if so what type of clothes
would you make and what would the name
of your clothing line be okay I got you
I sang at last because well one I had no
idea was the TV show I was just they
asked me this thing a song I had no idea
I was there but I was pretty certain it
paid some money and I was like cool why
do you want me to sing and so I was
about to sing at a wedding and I was
singing at last at the wedding side just
saying that cuz I was about to sing it
somewhere I made my own clothes not
because I'm super into fashion but
because my place had just burned down
and all my belongings but pictures were
gone so those were actually jeans that I
cut and put safety pins in them and made
a shirt because I'm so cool
if I ever had a fashion line it would
definitely be just jeans and t-shirts
[Applause]
yeah burn Oh burned out that's what
we're going to matching young girls with
women who can guide them toward their
dreams so I have someone here I want you
to meet I know you're a big fan of her
so we've been keeping this a special
secret all day long that's why you've
been trapped in a room sorry Ariana will
you come out
[Applause]
all right so what do this is crazy we've
been trying to hide this from you all
day you're like why did they lock me in
a room without a TV no good snacks in
here like it's outing but what advice
would you give to her Ariana being a
journalist about your amazing you in the
arm because as you said about Kevin Hart
you know not everything goes perfectly
in life so remember whatever happens you
are amazing you keep believing in
yourself
and I want you to come an intern for one
day at thrive globe
you can interview anyone who works there
about anything you want including maybe
asking them how much time they spend on
social media do they compare themselves
with Kate Upton
and then we will publish it on thrive
global that's amazing what do you feel
how do you feel amazing
I actually have a surprised a special
surprise for you
from our friends at Access Hollywood
you're actually gonna spend a day
interning there as well you'll get to
meet Mario Lopez and see what it takes
to be a top notch entertainment news
reporter does that so good yeah I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this